♪ [upbeat music plays]
Webb Brown: We started DayZipping
in July of last year.
And it was really born out of the idea
of I was an investment banker
and I was working all the time.
And never really knew when I was gonna
have free time on the weekends
or what city I was gonna be in.
So it felt like it was really tough
to find stuff real-time
when I say I have four hours
on a Saturday to spent in Chicago,
or San Francisco,
or wherever I might be.
So, that led to the idea of DayZipping.
And our site is still relatively small.
It started in July of last year,
but right now we're at around
10, 000 uniques
and a 100, 000 page views a month.
Paul Godfrey: Most of our trips
are user-generated.
And some of our users
had already provided us
with a great set of trips for San Francisco.
One thing I wanted to do here
specifically was go visit Alcatraz.
And that was just a fantastic
write up on that,
on DayZipping.
Another thing is hiking in Muir Woods.
Those are two great trips that we've
been able to take while we're in town,
thanks to our great users.
So we did a pretty thorough technology
review before we started development.
We looked at Ruby, Python,
a couple different products.
But the fundamental choice that
led us to use Google Web Toolkit
was the performance benefits.
Webb Brown: Our site scaled
really well because of using GWT.
Because we have so much
of our business logic
and the actual code
being run on the client machine,
as opposed to our web server.
What it allowed us to do
was iterate really quickly
and build a lot of different features
and test a lot of different things
and not spend a lot of time focusing
on optimization and performance.
All the inherent benefits of using GWT
took care of that for us.
So it's been great.
It's let us build new features
and use stuff like Client Bundling
and Perfect Caching
and still have a fast site.
And for us, as a consumer
internet company
where people are viewing photos
and viewing trips
and really bouncing around pages a lot,
that's probably the most
important factor for us.
00:02:00.167,00:00:00.000